I see no obstacle to computers
eventually,
uh,
becoming conscious in some sense.
That'll be a fascinating experience.
Um,
as a physicist,
I want to know if those computers do
physics the same way humans do physics
and there's no doubt that those machines
will be able to,
um,
evolve computationally potentially at a
faster rate than humans.
And in the long term,
the,
um,
ultimate highest forms of consciousness
on the planet may not be purely
biological,
but that's not necessarily a bad thing.
We always present computers as if they
don't have capabilities of empathy or a
emotion,
but I would think that any intelligent
machine would ultimately have experience
that it's a learning machine and
ultimately it would learn from its
experience like a,
like a biological conscious being.
And therefore it's hard for me to
believe that it would not be able to
have many of the characteristics that we
now associate with being human.
Elon Musk and others who have expressed
concern and Stephen Hawking are friends
of mine and I understand their potential
concerns,
but I'm frankly not as concerned about
ai in the near term,
at the very least,
as many many of my friends and
colleagues are.
It's far less powerful than people
imagined.
I mean,
you try to get a robot to fold laundry
and I've just been told you can't even
get full robot to fold laundry at.
Someone just wrote me.
They were surprised when I said an
elevator is an old example of the fact
that when you get an elevator,
you're,
it's a primitive form of a computer and
you're and you're giving up control of
the of the fact that it's going to take
you where you want to go.
Cars are the same thing.
Machines are useful because they're
tools that help us do we want to do,
and I think computation machines are
exempt,
are good examples of that.
One has to be very careful in creating
machines to not assume they're more
capable than they are.
That's true in cars.
That's true in vehicles that we make.
That's true in weapons.
We create that's true in defensive
mechanisms we create and so to me,
the dangers of Ai,
what are mostly due to the fact that
people may assume the devices they
create are more capable than they are
and don't need more control and
monitoring.
I guess I find the opportunities to be
far more exciting than the dangers.
The unknown is always dangerous,
but
ultimately machines and computational
machines are
improving our lives in many ways.
We of course have to realize that the
rate at which machines are,
are evolving in capability may far
exceed the rate at which society is able
to deal with them.
The fact that teenagers aren't talking
to each other,
but always looking at their phones,
not just teenagers.
I was just in a restaurant here,
New York this afternoon and half the
people were not talking to people they
were with,
but we're staring at their phones.
While that may be not a good thing for
societal interaction and people may have
to come to terms with that,
but I don't think people view their
phones as a danger.
They view their phones as a tool that in
many ways,
um,
allow them to do what they would
otherwise do more effectively.